good morning believe nation today's
message is be different over to you
Alicia Keys even when I was you know
just just starting I was different and
you know I looked way different and I
played the piano and I had the breeze
and I was like straight off of the
sheets in New York
people always told me like don't you you
know you should be wearing dresses and
be and it's just what wasn't really was
never my thing like my thing I wanted to
be the everyday girl that I was and be
able to relate to other women and girls
and and be able to just like be who I
was because I didn't see myself in the
music or in the entertainment world or
whatever and so and so now I feel like I
have actually really come back to that
place I'm really recognizing you know
I've always been that person and you
know as you grow you try different
things and you go different places but
that's where I'm the most comfortable
and that's where I really am able to be
truly myself so I think people care way
way way way way too much what other
people think of them I think people hold
themselves back so much every single day
based off of what other people think of
them how many decisions have you made in
the past week based off of worrying what
somebody else might think of you whether
that's your friends your family you know
the people around you somebody you're
worried about how you might be seen and
so you don't take that action that you
want to take you don't go out and do
that thing that you want to do only
because your fear being judged
so you intentionally hold yourself back
from potentially doing an amazing thing
from expressing yourself from
discovering something about yourself or
potentially creating a big impact in
this new area because you're worried
about what someone's gonna think about
you and that sucks you need to change
that the only way you're going to go out
and really unlock your talent and really
be that best version of yourself is to
care only really what you think about
yourself and not what other people think
about you now that doesn't mean you go
out and screw other people over right
doesn't mean you're doing things to
intentionally upset somebody I'm not
saying that but what does it matter what
your clothes are why do you have to wear
a certain thing or why do you have to go
into a certain profession why do you
have to take a certain action really if
it doesn't support who you are what you
want to do you will never
reach your potential if you are just
living other people's version of your
life it's never gonna happen
and since Alicia Keys was talking about
clothes I think about my example when I
was starting up as an entrepreneur I
used to always wear a suit and tie so
whether I did interviews or meetings
connecting with somebody trade shows
speaking gigs I would always have a suit
and tie on
I felt honestly that I was young and
that people wouldn't respect me unless I
had a suit on and so I was worried about
what other people cared about me what
they thought about me and so it changed
how I acted and I didn't wear a suit
day-to-day I wasn't a suit guy and never
enjoyed wearing a suit and I would put
on a suit to try to make these other
people like me more and as I grew more
confident that's all it was just self
confidence as I grew more confident in
myself I started losing the suit and it
became a shirt and a blazer and then it
became a polo shirt and then it you know
went down to having a hoodie and a
t-shirt like I'm we're gonna t-shirt on
my channel now this is what I wear I
wear t-shirts I wear hoodies I feel most
like myself doing it and I don't care
what other people think about me if you
don't want to watch my channel because
I'm wearing a t-shirt instead of a suit
and tie it doesn't matter to me because
me dressing up in a suit and tie and not
being myself will always yield a worse
result than me being myself and
potentially losing a few people always I
remember this one event that I had to go
to where I was a keynote speaker and
they asked me to give out an award at a
black-tie dinner and I don't even own a
tuxedo I don't want to wear a tuxedo and
so I showed up at the black-tie dinner
to give out the award in my beliebe
hoodie in my five toed shoes and I had
business pants on and I didn't care and
because I didn't care nobody else really
cared and I think you need to feel
comfortable in your own skin and the
people who judge you they're just living
small they're just so insecure about
themselves that they have to put it on
to you those people think about the
people that are judging
you think about the people who you're so
worried about are any of them off doing
amazing things or any of them reaching
their potential or any of them people
that you really admire and look up to
say I want to be like that person No
so why do you care so much about them to
the part where you limit yourself of
what you can do it's crazy you are
different you have to be different you
have to discover yourself you have to
unlock that potential
so stop caring what other people think
about you just do you with that star
shine let it come out and make something
amazing so the question of the day today
is I'm curious what's the most different
thing about you let's celebrate your
differences leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching and have
an amazing day I believe in you I hope
we continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of Enter